what's not exactly the Rolling Stones on
tour but Hillary Clinton's endless
excuses world tour is doing a brisk
business still Clinton was recently in
the United Kingdom where she began
complaining about the American electoral
system here's a selection now in the
u.s. it was a perfect storm deep
currents of anger and resentment flowing
through our culture a political press
that told voters my emails were the most
important story unprecedented
intervention in our election by the FBI
and an information warfare campaign
waged from the Kremlin aides from the
Kremlin the darkest recesses of the
Kremlin no doubt but the 2016 election
is still a topic of conversation the
President himself brought it up last
night during his rally in South Carolina
here's a selection from that she writes
a book and she does a tour and she how
many how many reasons did she give for
losing the election like every week it
was a different reason right
she blamed everybody for losing the
election except for one person herself
timmi Bruce is a radio show host in New
York and obviously a frequent and
treasured guest on the show and she
joins us tonight Tammy I don't want to
carry water for the Kremlin but I can't
resist asking what do you think this is
about I've asked you this many times but
I'm still baffled well look and it
really matches what we've been
discussing earlier in the show about the
left-wing reaction to the election based
in emotion no facts it has nothing to do
with policy it has everything to do with
just some self obsession if you will and
rage so here you've got she's she's on
foreign soil
in addition Tucker doing this and yet
now she's also not even confronting
Trump about policy about she would have
better ideas and this is the problem in
that speech he also compared him to
Turkey's tyrannical her on a man who
just got re-elected and you know that is
in and of itself is a remarkable dynamic
but she still it personally for some
reason it can't resolve the fact that
she failed that this was not going to
happen and indeed when she talks about
you know a Russian conspiracy it really
was about the disassembled basic
decisions in the campaign like not going
to Wisconsin as an example very basic
campaign decision-making that I think
contributed to that failure so you think
this is an example of a public figure
basically living out her emotional life
in public yes and that and you look as a
woman and I want women in power and work
were terrific leaders the fact that this
has become almost a stereotypical
cartoon of what happens with with a
woman you know misogynists argue that
women aren't rational that we don't look
and deal with the issues properly that
we can't be reasoned with this is not
helpful and it is a shame and at the
same time here right she's arguing in
when she argues against the electoral
college is an example she's arguing that
the entire Republican structure of the
United States is at fault as well that
it's the founders now who are the
problem who are now to be blamed and I
think that she's a representation also
of what's happening here at home with
the left and what
going on now with all of the harassment
and violence not helpful that is exactly
right I think I think you know how
candidly a lot of people who supported
or probably feel that way too but they
can a minute yeah 10 verse thank you for
that thanks for having loose edition
thank you